well it's great to be
you today finger and it's a I've been
learning about your work since we
started talking a couple years ago and
I'm very impressed with how deeply it
resonates with some of the big themes at
Microsoft Research and that's why it's
so lovely to be here cuz there's a lot
of connection between the stuff that I
care about and the work that you all
have been doing it seems like you have
you have a passion here and not for AI
only but AI in the context of society
and humans and it's like I sense good
good collaboration prospects you
question well you have a deep passion
about about the the collaboration
between machine intellects and and
people humans and broader societal
implications in their uses of uses of AI
how did that get started what was your
group just get going in that space yeah
so I did my PhD at CMU in the robotics
Institute to to adviser their citroen a
Vasa was now at u-dub in Seattle so he
was running a primarily a manipulation
lab robots in kitchens picking up stuff
actually getting robots to use their
arms and their hands to do things in the
physical world and I joined this lab and
we were part of the quality of life
Technology Institute great phrase the
quality of life yes was an empowering
people to live independently in their
home for longer was part of the mission
so aging-in-place Aging in Place and but
we were we were in manipulation lab and
so I started I had the background and
optimization I always loved optimization
I still do optimization but remember
have to say this I don't like the
afternoon where we learned about
differentiation and setting the second
derivative to 2x and the first
derivative to Y and saying oh my god we
can optimize some function I remember
like in in like middle school being so
excited about that so that's I have two
skills one of them is taking gradients
the other one is
Bayes rule that's all I know how to do
those are the two things that I do but
but you know if you know those two
things I think you're set for almost
anything just I build a career on
modeling people as doing Bayes rule and
optimization and I getting robots to do
Bayes rule and after my passion about
Bayes rule in optimization that's kind
of the whiteboard for AI yeah that's
your pens and your whiteboard now though
no go yeah so so how did I get into it
while I was working on motion planning
and for manipulation and I I started
wondering how that fits in the context
of okay we want this robot to be in a
kitchen motion planning that's great but
aren't there going to be people in that
kitchen do we want them to leave the
kitchen when the robot is referring them
a meal or should they be able to you
know stick around and be assisted helped
by the robot empowered to do the things
that they would normally do it to
somebody when there's a little bruises
and then they come tell you that
oh they got to close during the peanut
butter and jelly assembly process and so
we started thinking about what does it
mean how does the the problem definition
for motion planning itself change from
this very functional one I have a goal I
have to be efficient maybe and I have to
avoid obstacles they have to avoid
collisions that was the definition how
does it change the moment the robot does
not operate in isolation anymore and
something sort of clicked at that point
for me because you know we started
thinking about okay we have a new
problem definition we have to integrate
this some notion of human state at least
the human observer if not a collaborator
at least a human observer into this mix
what does that mean and that was the
birth of my thesis which we called
legible robot motion planning and it was
with your Bayes rule it was this notion
that the moment you have an observer
that observer is making inferences about
what the robot might do next and that
it's not just important for the robot to
do its task reach its goal but it's
important to for it to do so in a way
that also enables the observer
to figure out what's going on now how do
you take so we wanted intent expression
we wanted functionality together with
intent expression and intent expression
was a very fuzzy concept but what we
managed to do again because I only know
two things we said well people probably
expect the robot to be doing some form
of art max because it's a robot so
that's a pretty reasonable assumption
and then we said okay what when they see
the robot moving
they're probably interpreting its motion
as evidence about what it is that the
robot is trying to do and there came in
Bayes rule so we had a base builder
running over this and that was our very
simple model of how humans might be
interpreting robot motion and that and
then the robot could actually be
optimizing to express intent that was
the story what it's a it's a great story
very expressive III do think that
sometimes I'm just integrating some
foundational structure data structures
variables dependencies inferences about
people in what was earlier a standalone
optimization without consideration of
people opens up such a rich space for
deep technical work and what makes it
really exciting is the link to
psychology humans I mean I'm assuming
that we're completely resonate on this I
did something very similar at the NASA
mission control center once and it just
lights up a whole area and raises so
many questions for example you know what
do people think about goals how do they
represent them how do you even represent
what people think about goals in your
optimization right and something in
Turkey about that right and and so the
the way I started seeing in over the
years was first this notion of okay now
they're gonna draw the box around just
the robot and the actions and the
physical environment right now and
that's what we typically think about AI
and then there's a reward function
exogenously falling from the sky let's
start drawing the box around the person
to write and and and so now we're
operating design
Nicolle system or at the very least
human state and not just physical state
may be internal state right their goals
or what they think about the robot that
becomes part of this dynamical system
that we need to be doing control over
and then it become it became a little
more complicated than even that recently
we've we've started in on almost on a
rabbit hole to realize that okay
thinking about this as a dynamical
system with human internal state is one
thing because then the robot can think
about making predictions about the human
state even making predictions about how
its own actions might influence human
state how he might guide people to take
certain actions and help them and the
task that they're trying to do but then
it became a little more complicated
because it turns out that sometimes
people also think about the robot and
try to influence the robot and so it
becomes very quickly a game theoretic
setting we've been digging into that
recently so an example that I like to
work with cars a lot these days I still
work with manipulator arms but I also
work with cars and an example that I
like to give is sort of with cars you
cannot get away without incorporating
human state into the picture right
because there's all these people around
so you you have to start making various
predictions about where these people
might be going and avoid collisions with
them so get out of their way and that's
a first pass but then it becomes more
complicated because you being the
automatic you made the automatic car and
then it becomes more complicated because
you end up if you do this you realize
that in sort of high-traffic crowded
situations if all you do is anticipate
where people go and make sure you're out
of the way at some point you can get
stuck what kind of four-way stops people
keep inching forward and you're stuck
there because you keep on anticipating
that they'll go and you stay out of
their way or in high-traffic situation
they try to change the lane it's hard
because people keep on coming and
there's not enough of a gap in traffic
and so that's difficult and then so then
you'd have to start as the cars the
autonomous car you have to start
reasoning about how you might actually
be able to influence these
predictions that you're making right
then you have some control of control
over it even the the you know the the
manners you display a little bit rushed
and punchy I'll basically make it clear
that I think I got to the stop sign in
for a way first being clear that's like
why go lots of communication micro
communication that goes on that's right
and it's true this almost like a bad
body language of the car and so the
reason I was saying it's it's because
game theoretical it's because not only
do you so you have to reason about your
influence on other people which is for
example the fact that they will likely
slow down if you go in front of them to
make space for you but then you also
have to be ready for the other side the
fact that people might try to influence
you and that is the example of someone
might actually when they see you come in
start accelerating to deter you from
going in front of them so as an
autonomous car yes you have to be clear
about what you want to do is that people
can respond you also have to be ready
for people responding you know non non
collaboratively they don't always
respond collaboratively and so there's
this mutual influence that's going on
and it's really difficult for a robot to
just sort of wrap its head around all of
this let me step back a little bit about
just the some essential challenges here
so we have a machine we even done our
best as researchers to incorporate a
bigger model that involves people and
their preferences and even their
understanding of what it is that I'm
doing as a robotic system yeah let's say
we don't get it right we're under a
sense for humans either understand or
believe or their goals or their
optimization function what they're
trying to do is different than what it
is is there a prospect for dialogue and
for kind of a back-and-forth you know in
a kind of a tangle of understanding so
good questions so I think of this at two
levels I want to talk about both the
first one is this notion of having
uncertainty over not assuming a fixed
model but having uncertainty over that
model right so different people like
differently the same person might change
their mind about something
work time and so I think it's important
their preferences we don't know what
people prefer we have no idea right so I
think it's important to for to deploy
these robots out into the world first of
all with a notion of uncertainty about
people not you know stubbornly thinking
they know what's up but actually being
able to incorporate the dialog in the
form of natural language or in the form
of of actions or connections or comment
here that in some ways it's it's
instilling a design principle of
humility in our systems yeah versus
overconfidence that's a very that's a
very nice way of putting it so yes I
think robots should go into this with
uncertainty as designers we can give
them a prior right ideally by collecting
data from a large set of people and
giving them a prior going in
I think the robots job is to be able to
leverage just a little bit of data
online very quickly to adjust to put
probability mass shift probability mass
around on to the sort of the hypothesis
that seems to be consistent with the
behavior of the humans so that's that's
one level right just being able to drive
okay right level one drive next to a
person and watch for what they're doing
and make inferences about their goal
about their preferences about their
driving style about whether they're
gonna let you in or nine so that's level
one level two is almost like a metal
level you can have all of this
uncertainty but if it's over the wrong
space right if you've baked in
assumptions that are actually wrong for
instance you can make you can if
something that bugs me a lot these days
is okay humans have preferences we want
to be flexible about their preferences
but what if there's just something that
they care about that we can't even
represent right either because we've
made the space of possible preference is
not expressive enough so maybe you know
people might care about not
inconveniencing others that has to be
part of something you can represent in
order for you to draw inferences over
that or it might be that people care
about their robots handling their
favorite mug from childhood
differently differently and what if the
robot just has no way using its sensors
to know that that's their favorite mug
from childhood right the has special
sentimental value they're just I think
we have to acknowledge that they're
gonna be things that we just the are
just gonna be outside of our hypothesis
if I tried even with an expressive
representation that some stuff is just
too hard to express and the effort it
would take is too much right right yeah
so you have to be careful you can have
expressive representations even with
these expressive so you can have a deep
neuron that as your model of preferences
and that's great except that one you
need a lot of data from the person maybe
you can use meta learning maybe you can
use priors but that that's still an
issue you can over represent you can
represent too much and you will still
underrepresented are not observable and
then there's the idea of kind of this
ambient watching and observing and
trying your best
as the robot versus robot saying I'm
uncertain and doing more explicit
dialogue about the preferences and go
let me actually act so that's the
beautiful thing about robots I like
robots because they take actions and
that means that they have this
opportunity to not just be passive
observers in gestures of information
people are people say stuff the robot
sits there and figures out what to do
but they can take what we call
information gathering actions and these
can have a traditional role right they
sorry a traditional format and machine
learning what their actual queries hey
human a or B what do you like or did you
mean this or that and that can can be
useful in resolving uncertainty
I like having robots also use their
physical actions to gain information do
you mean this right and so can I make a
query force the person to give you a
correction or and see how they might do
something see how they react to you with
door sign was now at Stanford their
society with it that's one right turn
with us yeah that's right that's
so right after she interned with you we
started working together PhD and so one
of the projects that we did together was
actually on information gathering
actions over human internal state this
notion that and this was for cars right
so this is what I I'm driving next to a
person I don't know if they're an
aggressive driver or they're paying
attention or not or they're just a
normal driver regular nominal driver I
don't know I have uncertainty over
that's that's that first principle and
and if it turns out that if you just
observe them passively you might never
know in time because there's they're
driving in the same way regardless of
right it's just they drive straight so
by incentivizing information gain all
right I meant ideally by making the
robot aware about the value of
information but in a continuous state in
action control setting we sort of cheat
and actually incentivize information
gain explicitly we were able to then get
these behavior optimization to emerge
where the car starts nudging towards
their lane not commuting to go but
nudging towards our lane to probe you
and see will you slow down or not to
learn to learn about whether it's
actually safe to then go in front of you
and expect rely on you to actually break
and make space for us actually it's easy
to executive value information probe
this is very interesting yeah if you can
do it safely and you know do this
subject to all of your constraints at an
intersection she got the car to inch
forward as the outcome of the so it's
interesting even in that situation the
inching forward emerged as a as a policy
but you could imagine it's also it was
anything there wasn't even a
consideration from that perspective of
inching forward as communicative
intention directly that's right and you
can Majan doing both some of that work
we weren't I kind of going back for the
beginning of the conversation now or we
weren't yet modeling people's beliefs
about the robots and then reacting to
that but we were just modeling the fact
that people try to be efficient try to
also be safe we don't know what specific
trade-offs they have we don't even know
if they're seeing the robot or not but
you know the algorithm essentially
figured out that an action that will
give it a lot of information is to start
inching forward and then watch for the
selection yeah it's fabulous fabulous
work i I think that some day this idea
of assessing preferences or utility
functions for robotic systems will
become more popular and more assumes I
thought that you know rather than then
talking about what a car will do a lot
of MIT a car will do in the trades it
makes and what are the value functions
that before you can even turn on an
automated system you'd have to watch
some videos in the in your car scene and
then set sliders as to what would you do
what are your preferences then when you
run the car you can assume that
automated car is when they are in
autopilot mode or automated mode that's
the preference function of the driver
who assess them might be interesting and
then when someone else gets in the same
car like in your family it's like all
the sliders change that it's like now
it's a new utility function that's right
become part of our normal life you go
into your car dealership and there's a
driving simulator there right and that's
cuz of your parameters that's where you
set your parameters you have to be
exposed to the behavior as well as sound
the videos and you can watch it right
think and in maybe a month later there's
a standard check back about preferences
yes I'll said it again but to understand
someday that when a car on automation
that's cutting you off or letting you
not yielding properly when you're coming
onto a highway that that's not the car
that's a driver or even worse automated
yeah I think I think customizing is it's
really understanding one thing that we
found this wasn't a pure this is
slightly atypical word for from what we
typically did this was really just we
set up a study and we wanted to see what
happened
um so we you know we wrote a paper that
started with the hypothesis in the
hypothesis was that people would like to
be driven the way they drive that that
matching the person's driving style is
what cars would need to do and we were
totally wrong I don't feel that way when
when my partner my wife is is driving
she drives like me I get really freaked
out I don't know if that's exactly right
you know I should have seen that coming
but I didn't so we ran this study and
basically what we found is that people
when we exposed so we did two things we
expose them to their driving style
without knowing it as theirs as well as
a more and more definitive an aggressive
one and then we asked them two things
one which one they prefer and two which
one they think is theirs and it turns
out basically the the moral of story is
people don't want cars to drive like
them they want cars that drive more
defensively but they think they want
cars to drive like them in other words
they yes if that's yeah if you ask them
yeah they they perceive their own style
as the more defensive style they can't
actually identify their style so they
think of themselves as more defensive
drivers than they actually are and it
makes sense exactly what you are saying
if someone is as aggressive as you well
you're not in there
my hypothesis at least my amateur
hypotheses about what's going on is that
I'm in a car if I'm the passenger of the
backseat driver I don't know that you
Eric have seen the pedestrian who plan
on stopping so I need you to start
slowing down earlier yeah yeah very
control it feels like everything's kind
of fluid and you know what you know what
you're good if you're not if you're
sitting in the bathroom very very
discomforting that's right yeah
everybody
thing let me as you a just a question
about background you know we often talk
about the pipeline and we see so far
fewer women in our field than men and
it's always intriguing to me as to why
that's the case what's the future how we
can do better and so that leads me to
ask questions when it comes to you know
really you know fabulously you know deep
thinking women in this field that are
who are leaders like what's the
background like how did you first get
excited about computer science and
mathematics and as you said optimization
and even Bayes rule yeah so I grew up in
Romania and I think that was an enormous
luck for me because and I stayed there
all the way through high school and I
only moved for college I went to Germany
for college but Romania is very
interesting because and this is
completely anecdotal and really just a
hypothesis but so take it with a grain
of salt but in Romania I feel look at
the number of bachelor degrees awarded
in stem over 50% of them go to women and
so that was a few years back I looked at
these numbers when I was in grad schools
they're a little stale but at that time
in Germany it was something like 20
something percent so you want okay why
why and my my hypothesis is that it's a
country in which everyone needs to be
good at math from the start right third
grade fourth grade fifth grade it
doesn't matter if you're a girl or we
don't have a lot of diversity other than
gender diverse Romania is a pretty
homogeneous country we're all white but
but so there's not a lot of diversity
with respect to you know what in u.s. we
think also not just about gender but we
think about underrepresented minority is
more broadly but but yeah in Romania
speaking about the gender issue it
everyone needs to be good at math and I
think that's kind of an equalizing thing
I think that that you never question
whether you're gonna be good or bad you
just you know you know you're gonna be
good
the idea of mathematics being critical
and yeah and you know their trade offs
because it comes at a constant it's
everyone appreciates math and I kid you
not at least back when I was in in high
school and middle school so I did the
math Olympiad and we were also the
people who would go out and and hang out
and have friends and be social maybe
this is somewhat of a good perspective
but I still think it's it's different
from what happens in the US where being
good at math is almost round upon and
being good at sports athletics I see
that mathematics was respected it was
goes respected and and not I still like
I want to go as far to say considered
cool but but there were a lot of of
there was a really good culture around
it and and you know good groups of
people social people also going out and
having fun and and just having good
relationships with with with other kids
in class who or not do also doing the
math only to write it was also just
suggest that you know for interventions
right in in countries where that's not
the case where we have a big disparity
then maybe thinking about what's the
culture what's the what's community
around the intellect intellectual
process will be very interesting and
equalizing things at that like that
level yeah yeah and then going from from
mathematics to getting excited about AI
and computers well cuz many computers in
there am i short thewhat the direction
was for you it was so I got into again
very lucky when when I was in fourth
grade we got to do some extracurriculars
and we've got to choose and my mom is
really baffled because she reminds me
that most of my peers chose dance music
I chose programming I went and turned
some QBasic pentium something maybe a
little earlier than that see for my foot
that's very modern so QBasic is what
will we learn me where I would
this little Club and I would teach me
cute basic and then I actually went to a
middle school high school combo that
started programming from the fifth grade
so I actually had it as part of my
curriculum and and I got excited about
it so I I kind of kept them side by side
it's all you know for me it's always
been math is very very appealing and
then algorithms are really appealing to
and she's putting that together I think
it's been something that I think you the
difference
that's embodiment so that's a good
question I think that there's a kind of
thinking about human robot interaction
there's there's algorithms you can write
down and it will make the robot maybe
interact with people in you know by
doing search by figuring some things out
I think then that there's magic and
bright
that's essentially committing to what is
my representation what is my model what
is my inductive bias that I'm gonna
allow myself around people and so they
and then there's the theoretical
statements that you might want to make
not that we've done a lot of that in the
realm of human robot interaction but
we're starting to so so you know you
want to ask questions like I have no
idea what human policies what real
people actually do but what do I need to
assume what are what are sufficient
conditions what are sufficient
assumptions for me to actually have a
robot that can help the person you've
jumped way to now but back to you back
to you that Beth grade those right
algorithms in math yeah so okay so I did
algorithms I did math I try to do all
them get some sort of both sides and
then I read Stuart's book in 12th grade
textbook with Peter Norvig by the way if
visiting us next week great so so I like
to tell the story because I read this
book and in it changed my world because
it was just so search and MDP is and all
of that was just somehow it clicked
somehow I realize cuz before then I
thought that I wanted to be a soft
engineer because that's what I knew
right I knew how to program and I knew
about algorithms and I thought that I
would be a software engineer and and
that's sort of through that book is at
the same time I discovered there's
something called research where you
invent the new algorithms because that's
cool I want to do that and and so I
really loved the topics in the book and
I went to do computer science and I try
to do research and even in my college I
got involved with research in the color
Julie listen in Germany in Raymond
yacouba's University brain man and it's
a little school international people
from a hundred different countries
altogether this little campus in Germany
it's a fantastic way way from there to
to CMU I went right from there at the
CMU right so I did three years of
bachelor's cuz that's the norm in
Germany and then I went at the robotics
Institute which again was kind of a
fluke because I hadn't done robots I had
done optimization and I thought oh well
but but robots are pretty interesting as
as an application of all of this you
know they move in the physical world so
you write some stuff and then instead of
pixels on the screen changing there's
something in the world that happens and
that was really exciting and even now I
mean I'm so I like the the still the arm
stuff but then so I say that mesial arm
stuff
you mean robotic arm yeah I hear haven't
seen your talk yet uh watching the
videos right and we stole this some work
on nine but I've had this newer
experience with just a unit to ride in
an autonomous car to be in a robot
that's really that's really exciting too
so I think that's that's how I got there
it's a lot of luck and a lot of being
exposed accidentally to the right things
at the right times now these days you as
we're seeing more and more you you're do
research at UC Berkeley you have a team
there and then part of your time you
spend in industry so what's that
experience like it's it's really a
privileged position to I feel like I'm
getting the best out of both worlds I
feel like
I my time with my students and it's
really where my core passion lies and we
get to think as Ford as we want right we
have I think that's the role of that we
have in academia and in industrial
research right that we don't have to
make anyone money in the next five years
and therefore we get to to think as far
ahead as we want and it's kind of our
responsibility to do things that
industry can't afford to do because they
actually have to be building products
and making things work for real and then
I get to do why do only do one day a
week but I got to do one day a week in
this other world of where I start seeing
something that I never thought all my
stuff has been so useless until now
because you know this uh this whole Oh
imagine that robot would actually work
and then we actually draw the Box around
the human - and think about how that
changes all of our algorithms starting
with the first one imagine it exists
actually would be useful yeah so and now
what cars it's really interesting
because with car so I I spend one day
weekend Waymon which is a really
fantastic opportunity and and that's one
of the major bottlenecks right if we
could have cars on the road without
pedestrians and cyclists and and human
drivers right I mean perception now
works well enough that it's and then you
can do planning and all of that and then
the only if things are that simple
yeah so I think it's it's really the
bottleneck is in these interactions this
back and forth that you have to have
with people these predictions the
influence that we were talking about all
of that has to come together for you to
actually be safe on on the road so I
take your passengers to where they need
to go so speaking about this energy and
enthusiasm let's let's now jump to 2045
which is basically you know it's like 25
years from now yeah no believe it I've
been at Microsoft 25 years like so I've
seen so much it's so much change and
it's been fabulous it's bad does arc
of Technology and society what's the
world like in 2045 and unless stop with
the good parts of things I mean in terms
of the surprises and the fun deployment
of technology it's it's I will confess
it's really hard for me to think about
this I tend to be this curmudgeon and I
only see what I think how things are
really hard not how things are really
easy but but I think there's a lot of
exciting things we can do right there's
a lot in the space of empowering people
in the space of assisting people on the
space of you know I always say that as
AI systems can get better I want us to
get better as well right I want I want
guidance from an AI system I want
something that that takes what I want to
be good at and helps me improve helps me
get better and I think you know you see
that example with with systems like
games right you play go now you discover
all these interesting moves and so as a
I can get better it's a good time to
think about okay how can go players get
better and go but I think you can bring
that into the real world too and I think
you can look at all of these tasks that
people might want to do and how you mind
sort of gently nudge them to to make
progress and and coach them and teach
them and have them become better over
time so a world where your mented and
empowered right by intellectual lead on
the electro side as well - robotics I
potentially that's really the other
thing of course that I remain excited
about is this going back to quality of
life technology so we're lucky to have
so Sergey xi and I scored by as a
student we have this collaborators at
UCSF who have taken a patient with
quadriplegia and implanted it's not
quite an electrode array but it's a
neural implant and so we're working on
how we might be leveraging a
state-of-the-art AI techniques to
empower this patient to
both um you know my favorite operate an
arm to do things they he wants to feed
himself that's a that's a thing that he
really is amazing we take for granted
so so thats a dream of ours to be able
to do something like that i was said to
be able to enable him to navigate he has
a textual interface and the most cursors
on a screen and so getting that to be to
be really seamless for him and so that
that you know we'll probably make a
little dents in that but I think that
that's an area that could that could
really become better and better and I
see I don't know if 45 or 55 for 75 I
have no notion of time skills here but
you can imagine this transitioning at
some point even there I say it to the
rest of the population you can imagine
that you can have devices that can but
you know you think stuff you don't have
to tie if you don't have you think stuff
and then you get things that know what
you want to do in and help you with it
it's interesting to to to see the rise
of interest in systems AI systems that
can explain their reasoning and in many
cases we we have trouble doing that as
researchers and scientists why why is
transparency or even X intelligibility
what it becoming such an important thing
then I think part of the reason it has
to do with calibrating trust so it's
important that people trust these
systems when they're useful but it's
also important that they don't trust
these systems when they're not useful
and so a large component of transparency
goes back to that right goes back to
this notion of okay there's there's some
things like I'm bad and some things
aren't good at and somehow and I don't
know as the robot what I'm good and bad
at but somehow that needs to come across
to the person one perspective that we've
gotten on this has been that over time
people if they just see enough examples
they can build up some mental model of a
systems capabilities but if their
subject matter experts so they can tell
what the thing is doing the correct
thing what not um we've we've been
looking in ways to accelerate that
process by explicitly searching for what
are examples to give the person that are
actually informative right so okay if
you just let the system be used over
time people figure it out what are the
things that we can do to expose people
to informative behaviors from the system
is interesting as a again an early
innovator in terms of maybe using too
much the Tesla autopilot even understand
and try to learn about where it wouldn't
do well beyond its own knowledge about
where it would do well effect it could
be very confident I go nope it's not
gonna do well there and I remember
telling some of my colleagues it was
like learning how to drive a horse
understand how to communicate and
understand what it precedes versus what
I was perceiving yeah and I think that
that's an example where it it does seem
really useful for people to very quickly
get up to speed and have an accurate
model of the capabilities and
limitations of that kind of system and
and it's really hard because you know
chances are it's a black box you know
network the designers themselves
probably don't understand the
capabilities and limitations very well
although some of the things you've just
given the sensors you have access to
might be might be inferable but but yeah
I think starting to think about okay
what maybe maybe you look at a policy
and you look at where the policy itself
thinks and so to say that it's really
important to take a particular kind of
action and maybe presents that to you
this is something that we call critical
states very very very simple concept the
idea is cluster ideas present them to
the person and now the person gets an
idea of okay this is what you do in
these situations and this is what you
think are important situations oh boy
this thing is
thing from here I wonder what you were
doing this other statement that that I
don't see as you're thinking is
important and sort of that again can be
some sort of interaction where you get
to query the system and building a more
accurate model over time I think the way
we've been thinking about transparency
over all you know it goes back to this
notion of their son it's it's it's like
rope it's the opposite robot if we
talked about human internal state and
how it's important for robots to
understand human internal state and how
honestly people could be informative
about try to be informative about their
preferences their internal state I think
the same applies to robots right robots
have internal state in the sense of
their stuff that the robot knows that
people don't and the robot has to
understand that it's actions that people
have may be believed so for this they
have some sort of mental model its
actions end up updating that mental
model so you have to be careful about
the actions that you're taking because
they're gonna be shifting that mental
model around and so it's it's an
opportunity now to take actions that are
gonna lead to the as quickly as possible
to you Eric knowing okay this is not the
kind of capability than my current car
or device has and this is getting back
to this sitting in the car watching the
videos or the simulator even you must
understand abilities surely what we do
we sit down and say okay here's the
thing that this policy finds important
and you know they they see the thing
driving and then we see when they
intervene excellent
bacon you know hopefully we get them to
intervene in states where the policy is
not good and not intervene in states
where the policy is good but or work in
progress now this video might be on the
web and you might look back upon it ten
years from now communicating to you
feature yourself ten years from now
what's a stretch goal you could say ten
years from now boy if I could do this
it'd be fabulous what's a stretch goal
to I've accomplished by then a decade
from now boy
everything feels like a stretch goal
that's a great answer but okay if I feel
that way exactly the same way I think I
feel it if if we're not working on
things that seem like stretch goals then
what are we doing all right that's it
like I was saying I you know like it's
our job and I I don't claim to always be
good that I you know we have undergrad
students that we're training and we need
to give them things that are not you
know maybe we can solve this in ten
years or not but but they had the real
problem stay there oh you for instance
this tool right make an AI tool wear
that that is it almost like a decision
support system for an engineer to be
able to define a reward function
correctly
no I'd rather do that great well it's
been great chatting with you thanks for
having me here